my name is sumeet Jane and I'm the
development director at unabridged
software I'm gonna talk to you today
about leveling up teams this
conversation of leveling up teams has
been going on for a long time now I
think since the coming of coding schools
we have found repeatedly over the past
several years to say nothing of the past
three days a constant stream of ideas
that we should value mentorship that
said I don't think that anybody
disagrees with that did anybody come to
rails con thinking mentorship is
worthless
and luckily over the past three days
you've been convinced finally that
mentorship is a good thing
probably not we all agree that
mentorship is valuable still I'd say
that life is harder for junior devs and
maybe it ever has been so there's some
kind of a disconnect somewhere right
what's the issue are we lying
are we just secretly haters of
mentorship I would argue actually some
of us are there's this idea I think for
a lot of developers that our skill isn't
Ruby our skill isn't sequel or
JavaScript our skill is that given
enough time we can solve any problem by
ourselves and so when we see that other
developers need active mentorship to
solve those same problems it's
borderline offensive and so it's worth
considering if you're building a
mentorship program at your company that
that attitude may be somewhere inside of
your developers that this idea that you
shouldn't need mentorship so why should
we work extra hard to provide it that's
probably a small minority of us I don't
think that most of us identify with that
attitude at least consciously for most
of us we just don't know how to mentor
there's a hopeful assumption that
mentorship skills are in you as long as
you've been doing this for long enough
and as long as you're good enough at it
but they're not intuitive skills
sometimes the very things that you think
you're doing that are going to be
valuable mentorship to your junior
developers or anything but and so given
that these aren't and
to ative skills I thought it would be
worthwhile to at least talk about things
you can do that over a long period of
time or a short period of time maybe you
will slowly become a better mentor and
these are not values judgments in fact
many of these tactics might not work for
you at all
I expect maybe for some of you none of
these are gonna be that useful
whatsoever so I've been tricked you
you're here now and it's rude to leave
so you're stuck with me but ultimately
what I'm hoping is not so much that you
get direct value out of every single one
of the numerous tactics I'm about to
present mostly is to consider this I
think you'll get more value out of
debating the merit of the tactics to
follow then you will from just taking
this idea that mentorship is good and
letting that simmer this passive idea
that if you let that value simmer you'll
just become better at mentorship to me
all that is is companies recognizing
that mentorship has become a trendy
value in the marketplace and now they
need to say that their mentors so you'll
do better disagreeing with these tactics
and debating them and mist yourselves
then you will just by taking the value
of mentorship at face value okay every
time you see a fun picture that's a
tactic coming up so the first one is
provided you have a lot of questions
being asked in whatever channels you use
for questions I would suggest codifying
some format for asking those questions
probably this is done implicitly already
because the pattern that I have in mind
is inherent to everything we do as
problem solvers let alone engineers I
would say that you can lint a question
in the same way that you can lint your
Ruby or JSON or anything else the
pattern that I think is the most useful
for question-asking is probably the one
that you expect and you expect it
because it's there in every single unit
test you've ever written codify it write
it down tell your employees your team
members this is how we ask questions now
what are you trying to accomplish give
me steps what did you expect to happen
and then what actually happened right
this is not a revelation for any of you
I would think because this is again
whatever
looks like but the idea that you can
make this an enforced format for every
question before you answer the question
I think that there's power to that
tactic the reason I like this is because
first it allows the question asker to
slowly more methodically understand
their question why are they struggling
well now they have to spell it out for
you sometimes they'll even get the
answer before they finish writing the
question the second reason I like it is
that it gives you the meant or the
question answerer a way to be helpful
without jumping to the end and just
giving them the answer as you help them
formulate the question because it's hard
to do this a lot of the times for
questions but as you help them formulate
the question in this way you're being
helpful
you're mentoring but you haven't jumped
to the end and saved them a Stack
Overflow instead you're walking them
through the process of solving problems
probably similarly to how you do okay
new image I'm going to kind of be
rushing through these not rushing but
I'm not going to spend as much time as
you might think I will on each slide
okay I know slack usage is a little bit
controversial today we're finding
ourselves distracted but if you're using
some channel for frequent communication
there's a good chance that that channel
allows for private messages like slack
does so what I'd like to suggest is a
rule that you can't have technical
conversations in slack private messages
anything that is technical I mean if
you've got an HR concern find a private
channel but if you have a technical
question of some kind put it in a public
channel or a private channel but put it
in the channel where all of the eyes for
that team can see it this does a few
things first it exposes the most
knowledge possible and pain points
there's a good chance if somebody else
is going to have that same question if
they don't already now they don't have
to ask it again and they've seen that
question asking is something that this
team does a lot of there's something
else that it does if you're the team
lead or in a position of leadership on
the team now you get to see what
the most frequent questions are and if
you can see what people are repeatedly
asking questions about that's a pain
point and that might be something worth
you investing some time in shoring up
operationally or the documentation or
something but if you don't have this
rule in place you're most insecure
developers the ones most in need of help
are going to be reaching out to people
privately and getting help and now you
don't see any of that there's a
sentiment about stupid questions that is
probably so prolific that you could
predict it without me even telling you
all of it it's everywhere you hear
people tell it to newcomers to any
industry to any field it's a way to give
them reassurance you don't have to shout
it out I'm not gonna do one of those all
right one two three but mumble amongst
yourselves if you feel like you know
what this is there's a good chance that
you've heard this time and time again I
would argue it is a Miss truth or at
least a partial miss truth there is such
a thing as a stupid question if only
because the asking of it makes that
person feel stupid it's not that the
question is inherently a stupid question
but if somebody has a question that they
don't feel empowered to ask telling them
look there's no such thing as a stupid
question it's not very helpful advice
instead let's accept the fact that as
humans we have ego and there's really
not much that a team can do to
completely negate the impact of having
an ego and so instead of just telling
people there's no such thing as a stupid
question give them a place to ask stupid
questions so why don't people ask stupid
questions
you've got the slack channel you've got
whatever room is there for general
technical questions but people won't ask
because it's not anonymous for the ones
that we feel the most insecure about we
don't want our co-workers to know that
that's something we don't know when we
hear for other developers over there
laughing hysterically about something
related to the codebase but we don't
even know what that thing is that's a
stupid question not because our actual
ignorance is stupid but again it makes
us feel that way so where do you go
IRC trained your developers on how to
connect to Ruby Ruby on Rails whatever
but there are channels full of
developers that at least in my
experience are maybe sometimes a little
bit short but helpful it's an anonymous
place where you can quickly get a new
alias if you find yourself feeling too
insecure to keep your old identity it's
a place where you can actually go and
ask questions that nobody else should
see from your perspective this doesn't
mean that companies are off the hook
right this doesn't mean that you get to
hold a culture where people should feel
bad for asking questions but at the very
least it gives your developers an outlet
when there is something that they just
can't quite muster the courage to ask
okay a little bit of a new frame then
one of the misconceptions about new devs
is that are that many seniors can have
that is is that they're struggling with
something due to a lack of coding
knowledge so when the junior and senior
work together the senior assumes that
the thing they need to explain is
related to how the code works or related
to how the rails framework works aside
from being unhelpful
that's that misdiagnosis can be
particularly infuriating for the junior
dev because first they're not struggling
because of the API I know there's
nothing on the slide by the way if
you're wondering first it's infuriating
for the new developer because that's not
why they have that problem and so you're
not being helpful but second it's also
infuriating because now they're afraid
that other people on their team
underestimate them so much that they're
explaining some basic part of the
application junior devs often have
enough coding knowledge to work their
way through a problem what they're
missing are business knowledge and
tooling think about what the path is or
what paths plural exist for getting
passed for getting unstuck when your
problem is code you can google it you'll
find stack overflows stick a binding dot
pry in it even just brute force trial
and error and you
sometimes we'll find an answer when your
problem is code what do you do though
when your problem is that you have eight
different classes and you understand
every single one but you still can't
solve the problem what do you do when
you know that a bug was caused by a form
submission three months ago but you
don't know how to get logs for that far
back that's frustrating because you feel
like you've learned the things that
you're supposed to know by now but it's
this extra knowledge outside of code
that's holding you back
business knowledge and tooling are among
the most opaque parts of writing
software to new devs this knowledge
tends to live just in the brains of your
senior most developers and it's why
we're so desperate to cling to them and
we don't want to lose them to any other
company it's because we recognize that
code knowledge while important tends to
be one of the first things that people
get proficient with and we need to hold
on to our seniors so there's no silver
bullet for this this is a very hard
problem to solve but a couple tactics
that might help first
consider removing or at least
documenting the abstractions that live
in your application that are everywhere
I'll explain what I mean by this it's
unlikely that a new developer is very
familiar with anything beyond the rails
way of doing something in your
application so if your application is
littered with patterns or abstractions
that change how forms work for example
it's going to be frustrating for a new
dev to jump in and find that what should
be an easy task is actually now
unfamiliar to them using cells or Draper
for views or virtus for your form
objects or other popular tools that
speed things up in rails for developers
that know enough about it to get them
that's one thing but you're going to
have a junior developer that you tell
very simply go add an update action to
that crud resource and they're like yes
finally I know all of those words I can
do this and then they look at it and it
looks nothing like what they learned and
that's because you have a layer of
abstraction between standard development
and your rails application and that was
never communicated maybe there's a small
line at the top that includes a module
that they're supposed to know
totally changes how active record is
going to handle that one form but they
haven't internalized the rails way as
much as you have and as a result it's
just a frustrating process for them and
now their self-doubt continues to bubble
these tools these patterns these things
that we do to make the life of a senior
developer easier they're not inherently
bad I'm not saying you have to kill all
of them what I am saying is that if
you're going to keep them you have to at
least discuss the ramifications on new
developers and how they'll take to your
application either remove them or write
something in a very clear place that
tells new developers this is a change
that we're making to how we develop
rails beyond your basic 15 minute blog
here's what you should check out to get
familiar with it so that you can
actually contribute one of the reasons
that you might be proud of your codebase
is that you have factored it down into
very small classes that each contain a
few concise methods we often talk about
how this makes code easier to reason
about easier to test all of that is true
but a trade off can sometimes be that it
makes it really hard to get a macro
level understanding of what's going on
that touches all of those small classes
sometimes it's a lot of effort to
traverse through the long chain of join
tables to figure out which one column
needs to be updated again there's no
silver bullet to fixing this method
documentation can help you understand
the input and output of a single method
but usually that doesn't help you with
the high level understanding of what
that class is about so the goal with
what I would call domain level
documentation but the term is confusing
call it whatever you like
the goal is simply to make the macro
intent of smaller classes more explicit
the more testable the more modular your
code is great but for humans trying to
get an understanding of the business
logic driving the need for 18 classes
that needs to live somewhere don't
assume that 28 consecutive belongs to
and has many statements
X
presses the full intent of some class
sometimes a paragraph at the top is a
lot that is a lot better it's easy for
me to say this standing up on the stage
go document all the domains in your
application go figure out a way to make
the macro-level explicit writing that
out is is a big job I get it it's not
easy to document a complex system that
said part of the reason why it's hard is
because as engineers we'd love to find
the perfect data structure for
documentation and that holds us back are
we going to use this folder structure
for our documentation should that big
block of code come and go at the top of
the class or should it be like a
markdown file in a subfolder of app
models all of those decisions will
eventually mean that you just don't
write anything a fix for this is using
screencasts as documentation don't write
it at all take five minutes record
yourself talking about those eighteen
classes explaining why those 28
consecutive Association lines mean what
they mean and put that in a Google Drive
no elegant data structure just five
minutes if it ends up being six no big
deal if it ends up being 20 honestly no
big deal there either just try to keep
it short record a video that explains to
the route of the viewer why this code
exists and what it does you'll make that
in a literal five-minute time period and
you don't have to worry about where it
goes just stick it in a Google Drive if
you end up with a whole bunch of them
figure out the folder structure and
stuff later don't worry about figuring
that out first if you are so blessed as
to have hundreds of documentation videos
you'll make time to put it into into a
folder structure what else
pair programming hair programming is
great if it's working for you keep doing
it it's a wonderful technique I have
nothing bad to say about it except that
sometimes it just doesn't work sometimes
it's hard to make it practical
sometimes the golf that exists between
two developers skill sets makes it so
that pairing is just frustrating for
everybody involved sometimes sometimes
the best thing is to just spend some
time helping the more junior developer
ramp-up context so that they are parable
instead of pairing consider just for a
while watching other devs work let go
for this time for a short while that we
need to have equity between every single
one of the developers on our team if
it's just not possible then you're not
doing anybody a favor by trying to force
it in you can get a lot out of watching
a more experienced developer just do
their job not really even expecting them
to teach you anything just sit next to
them for 20 minutes two hours or
whatever is comfortable just watch them
sometimes experienced devs don't even
have the awareness of how much they know
and so they can't teach you it because
they're not even aware that they know it
so they're unconscious competence is now
a barrier to teaching and so instead
just let them watch sit somebody next to
you and consider all the things that
they are learning that you would have
forgotten to call out directly if you
were trying to teach them how you
phrased that Google query the manic but
methodical way that your mouse moves
around technical documentation because
you've learned to intuit
where the meaningful bits are gonna go
how you organize your screen shortcuts
you use in your code editor how you
debug in production by grepping for the
unique ID of some record things that
again you would just do but now they're
seeing you do it and as very intelligent
pattern detectors you'll find that they
are picking up on a lot of what you're
doing without even realizing it
amidst all of this chat about training
and mentorship it's easy to forget about
the after after you've got a team that
is suitably leveled up don't lose them
stick on to your talent you invested in
them hopefully and you want them to
continue to grow within your company
these are big topics so tactics for
these could be really an entire
conference unto themselves but a couple
things that I think are useful
especially within the context of junior
devs in this industry affirm the hire
this is a difficult field that we've all
chosen right every day we solve problems
that feel just a little bit beyond our
abilities and then somehow we find a
solution anyways we've learned to live
inside of that fear uncertainty
frustration and it's it's very engaging
work but it's very difficult work and
for a junior developer sometimes that
job is double difficult because they're
doing it while also trying to silence a
raging self-doubt that they don't
actually belong on your team and if you
just ignore it and pretend that that's
not there and let their smile tell you
the full story then you're missing out
on a big part of the dynamic inside of
your team it is such a small action but
for some of your more insecure new hires
or really just for all of them in your
one-on-ones simply saying you were a
good hire could go miles just to let
them know that though they may have
self-doubt there a good part of the team
and things will get better eventually
but at least you've minik mitigated to
some degree this idea that they're
afraid that they should never have been
hired in the first place or that they're
gone as soon as you find somebody a
little bit more competent that fear will
be in them and it'll be easy for you to
ameliorate it this one's a little bit
harder to explain let me paint a picture
five devs on a team there's the boss
three experienced devs and then one
newer developer
everyday everybody works hard but of
course like with a lot of teams there's
a bit of gift sharing and slack and
there's some chitchat in the hallways
about unrelated things when that happens
usually it's the three experienced devs
that are doing most of the gift sharing
most of the chitchat right if you're a
more junior developer in the audience
you're probably gonna relate to this one
person right the more junior developer
if you're maybe a tech lead or an
engineering manager maybe you're
thinking you're the boss whatever you
are consider that as the story finishes
the three developers are enjoying
themselves chatting taking their breaks
it's not like they're doing a bad thing
wasting time it's part of the acceptable
amount of the day that we want people to
waste 20 minutes 30 minutes whatever
your culture might be for hours and so
the question is why isn't the boss
joining in and why isn't the junior dev
joining in and the reason maybe could be
that the junior developer won't join in
because they're afraid that if they are
seen to be having fun that the secret's
out the reason they're getting just one
story point done every sprint is because
they're having too much fun hanging out
with everybody they don't want to seem
like they're enjoying their job they
want to be like the boss who's heads
down all the time working through the
day and so there are a few fixes to this
one is better communication on your team
tell people that it's okay to waste time
that they should have breaks as part of
their day some teams are better about
this than others some teams are really
good at doing this without saying
anything it's just part of the the
personality or the ethos of the people
leading the team but think about what it
is for your team and at least be
deliberate about it I would say though
that the best fix for this doesn't come
from any of the employees it comes from
the boss if you're an engineering
manager and you feel like you are always
heads down and you feel like the tone
that you're setting on your team is one
that taking 20 to 40 minutes out every
day for a break is no is no good add
five minutes to your calendar every
single day to deliberately waste time
with your employees just see what
happens give yourself that break you
probably need it too
a lot has been said and written about
investment time I've written a little
bit longer of an article about this
which if you wanted to learn more about
my thoughts on it you could read but
just a couple things here that I wanted
to point out if you're not familiar
investment time is at some companies
like Fridays every lunch they'll lecture
on some gem that they're learning about
or or or something like that but it's
any kind of extracurricular so to speak
work that's done and supported by the
company I'm a fan of it but I think that
sometimes teams squander opportunities
to get the most out of investment time
mostly this has to do with failing to
prioritize depth over breadth most of
the investment time that I hear about is
things like Oh on Friday I'm gonna have
we're gonna have lunch brought in and
one of our devs is going to talk about a
new JavaScript framework that they've
been tinkering around with but the
problem is that developers don't need
another avenue for getting breadth added
to their world they're getting that
already breadth of tech
ecosystem is being flung at them from
every direction depth is elusive how do
you factor depth building into your
investment time I think before II before
I talk about how you would do that a
quick point about this is that if you
were to talk about talk to the people on
your team who do have depth talk to your
most senior developers ask them how they
got that way
did they read some article that gave
them depth did they read eight articles
do they read 800 articles it gave them
depth I doubt it
most of the developers on your team that
have depth got it because at the
previous job or previous previous job
they were the only dev and they needed
to learn some skills and so it's
irrational to expect anybody else to
build depth any other way you have to
create an environment where you're less
senior devs are going to be confronted
by the need to build that depth so give
them a long-running project give them
something big to build that isn't going
to have stakeholders breathing down
their neck the whole time let them work
on it for a long time let them launch
it and let them find that there are
issues with scaling it or let them add
some of those patterns that end up being
prolific across the app and see how they
fare with them but let them do whatever
you would have the other senior devs do
and just don't let the senior devs touch
it because this is something that's
meant to provide depth to the newer
developers not Brett so I would really
reconsider the learning lunch approach
because as much fun as it is and it's
good for team bonding it might be
sacrificing an opportunity to add depth
to a team and instead just doing it
easier let me introduce you to one gem
per week type of mentality and finally
if you are going to do this try to
allocate enough time to hours every
Friday for lunch it's just not enough
that's first of all it's to more context
switches in the day mostly it's just not
enough time to really write any code to
get deep in anything so give it a full
day if you can
leveling up your developers continues as
you want them to become bigger parts of
the industry if you want your developers
to eventually come to conferences and
speak you can have them start to write
prose every time they implement
something new at your company have them
write a tutorial about how they did it
so one of them implements elasticsearch
in your application great have them
write a blog article about that process
and then stick it on the company blog
benefits of this are actually pretty
numerous because for one thing when you
are writing something for the first time
or implementing a new utility for the
first time you're probably just
following some kind of paint by the
numbers implementation of it but you're
gonna miss some things and when you
write an article it forces you to
crystallize what you've just learned
also you're more senior devs
can do a technical edit of that article
and find that there are things you
should have mentioned but didn't and
maybe that's a gap in the knowledge that
the junior developer has it creates
documentation every time you do this
that's internal documentation that
explains for that application why we use
to this pattern or this library and of
course as I mentioned it builds
Authority your junior developers your
senior developers everybody's going to
benefit from boosting their personal
brand
your company as well can benefit from
that some of the most well respected
companies at this conference as Ruby
consultancies made a lot of their
authority through the writing of these
blog articles maybe they do great work
maybe they maybe that work is not
meaningfully greater than everybody else
but that brand is untouchable this is
the last one I've got people in general
and engineers specifically are very very
good at gleaning wisdom from patterns
and so for example how you manage a
meeting if that's what you're doing
right now how you manage a meeting
probably has a lot to do with how
meetings were managed at your last two
jobs nobody ever sat you down and said
aleck let me teach you how to manage a
meeting step by step
right probably you just saw it done at
some point somebody asked you to do it
and then you did your best to
confidently recreate what you had seen
for many years and that's how we train
our managers at some point some of your
devs will want to become tech leads and
instead of having a more abrupt
transition into that role just let them
audit those meetings now let your devs
see what it looks like inside of a mock
up review session let them see what a
sprint planning meeting looks like let
them see what it looks like when
stakeholders are part of it and how the
tone changes all of a sudden give your
devs the opportunity to have
extracurricular knowledge being built
and slowly they'll start to bring other
people up with them as well I probably
should have switched the slide before
but this is what I just said
at the end of the day like I said this
is not about here's a playbook
go fall of these things exactly and now
you have a mentorship driven team what
I'd really prefer is that you ask
yourselves and ask your team if these
are things that would be useful for you
and sometimes they won't be but that
debate
I still think would yield more value
than just thinking to yourself
mentorship we need to be it that's not
going to give you a lot disagree if
you'd like to but at the end of the day
this is going to give you more return
than anything else I mean I said no
values judgments but this is at least
one your junior devs are probably more
competent than you give them credit for
and if you try to help them without
listening to them there's a good chance
that you're just gonna frustrate them
miss the mark on what they're actually
asking you and every time you do that
you make the next session of pairing the
next instructional session harder so
debate this stuff amidst yourselves but
also listen to your devs as you continue
this is something I started working on
just today I don't know if it's gonna be
useful or not this is not the actual
thing but it's a screenshot of the
various tactics that I've talked about
today aligned with some of the values
that I think they might provide like
questioning format might help other
people become better mentors this is
about a fourth of the table which I
haven't actually styled up much yet but
it is on my website so if you want to
look at the whole thing you can look at
it your X's might go in different places
than where I place them but again the
point is to mostly talk about it not to
just take this as a concrete plan of
action if you do want to look at slides
they're up now and if you want to talk
to me good luck I'm gonna be leaving for
a flight pretty soon but you can tweet
at me it's me Jane as I mentioned them
the development director at unabridged
software we're in Omaha Nebraska if you
are looking to hire consultancy or if
you're looking to work at a consultancy
let me know and I'd love to put you in
touch with the right people that's all
I've got thank you
[Applause]